Meeresgrundweckbomben, Meeresgrundweckbomben, Meeresgrundweckbomben, Meeresgrundweckbomben, Ist das Zufall? Du hast ja eh gesagt, Meeresgrundweckbomben. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast Sufo, mir gegenüber sitzt. Mittlerweile hat man sich daran gewöhnt. Stefan Titzlinghausen, hallo. Man hat sich daran gewöhnt, das finde ich auch gut. Herzlich willkommen, Florentin Will, den ihr natürlich auch alle mittlerweile kennen dürftet. F-L-U-R-E-N-T-I-N-W-I-L-L. Genau, weil so viele Nachfragen kamen, wie man meinen Namen genau schreibt. Ich weiß nicht, warum plötzlich alle meinen Namen schreiben wollen, aber ich finde es gut. Auch wenn ich kein Fan von Grußkarten bin, aber ich bin ein großer Fan von den tollen Intros, die ihr uns immer schickt, wie diese Woche von Randy. Kurz knacke ich auf den Punkt und fucking cooler Name, Randy. Randy! Nicht schlecht, Randy, Musiker, cooler Name, hat eigentlich schon direkt gewonnen. Wer Randy heißt, ist am Ziel. Ich glaube, du bist Quarterback, auch wenn es es sowas in Deutschlandgemeinden nicht gibt. Ich glaube, an deiner Schule hat man einfach diese Funktion, man wusste auch nicht genau, was es war in der Schule, aber man dachte, wir haben Randy, wir kriegen Randy. Lass uns, du bist jetzt Quarterback. Du bist Quarterback und Homecoming King. Wir wissen nicht, was ist, aber du darfst jetzt diese Krone tragen und diesen Baseball. Und seitdem ist er, glaube ich, durch die Schule gelaufen und hat Mitschüler verprügelt. Ja, absolut. Weil that's what Randys do. Und es wurden extra Spinde installiert, damit Randys seine Mitschüler in die Spinde sperren kann. Seitdem unbenutzt. Ich glaube ja, es gibt Spinde wegen des Geräusches. Dieses metallende Schüler-Fleisch-auf-Metall-Geräusches. Das kann man schlecht lahm machen, aber das verstehst du, was ich meine. Und für diese kurzen Momente, wo man den Spinn zumacht, aber dahinter ist dann dein Crush. Oder der Schulbully. Eins von beiden. Finde ich gut. Ich hätte auch keinen Spinne gehabt. Irgendwann wurden die bei uns an der Schule auch eingeführt, als modernes, neues... Ja, aber so kleine Schliessfachfächer. Kleine, quadratische Schliessfächer. Die viel mehr Sinn ergeben, machen uns nichts vor. Ja, aber es hat nicht diesen coolen Tsch. Aber dadurch, dass du halt mehrere übereinander hattest, konntest du halt viel mehr Cute-Meets generieren. Im Sinne von, oh, du hast den Spinn über mir, unter mir. Rein mathematisch hast du mehr Nachbarn automatisch. Nicht nur zwei, sondern acht. Und deswegen konntest du direkt viel mehr Leute kennen. Wie viele Ecken? Du als Schafspieler musst das auch wissen. Vier. Und wenn du in der Ecke oben warst, hast du aber auch nur zwei gehabt. Du meinst direkte Nachbarn mit Längsseite zu Längsseite. Wir hatten so Bienenförmige, deswegen hatte ich noch mehr Nachbarn. Meine Spinde waren so achteckig, weißt du? Ja. Ich weiß, Bienen haben sechsecken. Spart euch die Kommentare. Nee, ich, also bei vier Seiten hast du vier Nachbarn, richtig? Ja, ich nehme die Ecken ja auch noch rein. Aber gut, die Regeln der Rom-Com sind ja breit dehnbar, haben wir ja letzte Woche gemerkt. Wir haben ja unser neues Skript geschrieben zum Thema Steuern macht Liebe, kann ich mein Herz von der Steuer absetzen? Der etwas sperrige Arbeitstitel, den wir momentan benutzen. Aber Universal Studio ist informiert, wir haben einmal eine Zentrale angerufen und gesagt, passt mal auf, da kommt bald was. Wir wollen noch nicht zu viel Spoiler. Ja, wir haben so einen RSVP immer rumgeschickt, so einen Save the Date. So einen Save the Date for the Save the Date for the Letter for the Box. Ja, aber finde ich gut, einfach mal unkomitiert einen Save theate rumschicken. Merkt euch mal am 10. November, macht euch da mal den Kalender frei.
Macht mal, glaubt euch.
Ich glaube, Save-the-Dates sind vor allem für selber.
Jetzt sind wir so weit gegangen, dass wir die Save-the-Dates rausgeschickt.
Auch gibt es in Deutschland auch nicht.
Das Problem mit den ganzen Witzen, die wir gerade machen,
die wir auch seit Jahrzehnten mittlerweile in diesem Podcast machen,
ist, wir geben keinen Sinn.
Langsam dämmert es uns. Langsam dämmert es mir. Es gibt keine Grundlage, die schweben in der Luft. Die Grundlage sind Filme. Ja. Amerika ist die Grundlage, wo alles ein bisschen weniger sinnvoll ist. Wir hatten es gerade mit den Spinden. Die sind da ja viel zu gross geraten, viel zu schwer, es passt viel zu viel rein. Unsere Spinden machen ja mehr Sinn, aber sind halt Schliessfächer. Deren Rechtssystem macht keinen Sinn, aber ist cooler. Aber ist nicht Fiktion realistischer als die Realität? Im Grunde schon. Und vielleicht heißt Randy einfach Reinhold oder so. Also man kann es sich ja mal von Spitznamen geben. Weil ich meine, ich sag mal so, letzte Woche habe ich einen kleinen Einblick in dein Privatleben bekommen. Ich habe nämlich schön ein paar Kumpel von dir getroffen. Wir haben. Und zwar habe ich Johnny kennengelernt. Und wow, Johnny ist ein guter Kerl. Ja, pass auf, und zwar war er die Genese. Wir hatten vor zwei Wochen über die Sportart Paddel gesprochen. Richtig, die viele von euch für einen Witz gehalten haben. Viele haben gesagt, ha ha ha, was erzählen die immer für ulkige Sachen, die beiden Ulkknaben da in dem Podcast. Haben dann aber mal gegoogelt und haben gemerkt, die Realität hat ihnen einen Paddelball ins Gesicht gespielt, denn sie haben gemerkt, oh nein, das war gar kein frivoler Scherz, sondern bittere, bittere, bittere Realität. Richtig, es gibt Paddelschläger, es gibt Paddelbälle, es gibt Paddelplätze, ich weiß nicht, ob es Paddel, Paddel oder Paddel heißt. Auch das wurde diskutiert, es ist populär in zwei Ländern, Spanien und Schweden. Und in Spanien sagt man Paddel und in Schweden sagt man Paddel. Das heißt, du kannst automatisch am Paddelplatz. In Schweden sagt man Paddel. In Schweden sagt man Paddel. Das heißt, du kannst jetzt schon immer, wenn du beim Paddelplatz auftauchst, signalisieren, welcher der beiden Weltmächte im Paddelsport du dich zuschreibst. Spannend, weil ich habe mit einem Argentinier gesprochen, einem Freundeskreis, dem ich bislang noch ferngehalten habe. Aber der argentinische Kumpel, der hat gesagt, er kennt das auch sehr gut. Paddel spielt man nämlich auch in Argentinien. Heißt, vielleicht geht es um spanisch sprechende Länder und Schweben. Kann auch sein. Aber ich habe meine Loyalitäten bereits gewählt. Und ich werde so schnell nicht von der Seite der gelb-blauen Flagge abweichen. Okay, sehr gut. Denn du hast so begeistert geklungen. Und ich hatte die ganze Zeit meine Kumpels Kevin und Johnny im Ohr, die die ganze Zeit eh schon mit mir mal Paddell spielen gehen wollten. Dann habe ich gesagt, komm, Flo und ihn, ich hätte eine kleine Überraschung für dich. Dann habe ich dich deine Augen verbunden. Ich habe es ein bisschen schon an dem paddelförmigen Rucksack gemerkt, den du dabei hattest. Eine sehr markante Form. Und mein Paddelshirt. Mein It's a Paddle, Paddelshirt. Ja. Ja. Und dann bin ich mit dir, ja, ich sehe schon, die Augen drehen sich wie exorzistmäßig nach oben. Er sucht nach einem Wortwitz für Padel, hat dann abgebrochen und mich wieder angeguckt. Ich habe einmal Padel verpflichtet. Was ist dein Lieblingssong von Padel? Für mich ist es Hello und Casa de Padel. Das waren meine drei Gags. Nur noch zehn für diese Folge. Damit habe ich meine Quote erfüllt. Dann bist du durch. Ich hatte meine Casa de Papel, Papadel, Scheiße. Jetzt muss ich wieder elf, ne? Ich fange von vorne. Wenn man das gerne vertut, muss man wieder von vorne anfangen. Hatte ich jetzt jedenfalls an, das war ein bisschen zu überraten, jedenfalls. Sind wir zum Platz gegangen, Florentin ist wie so ein aufgeregter Hund, dem man zum ersten Mal irgendwie Schnee zeigen kann, wild rumgelaufen, ist direkt zu der Tür gelaufen, die es wirklich gibt. Die es tatsächlich gibt. Wer es jetzt nicht vor Augen hat, das Tolle an Paddel oder Paddel ist, es ist wie Tennis in einem Glaskasten, der Glaskasten ist aber oben offen. Das heißt, man kann den Ball auch auf den Boden dotzen lassen und dann fliegt er aus dem Spielfeld raus, damit kriegt die gegnerische Mannschaft einen Punkt.
Nicht ganz, denn man kann noch, wenn man möchte. Es wird wie so ein Werbespot für Kinder, so auf Kika. Doch es geht noch besser, denn man kann, wenn man will, Voraussetzung ist, man will das, dann kann man durch die Tür laufen, die auf der Höhe des Netzes ist und rauslaufen und den Ball nochmal spielen. Was ich grossartig finde, weil egal was das gegnerische Team gemacht hat, ich bin immer sofort aus der Tür rausgerannt, habe Stefan alleine in seinem Spielfeld zurückgelassen, er hat erstmal geflucht, du bist sehr aggressiv auf dem Feld, muss man sagen, erstmal geflucht und hat dann oft, weil er so viel geflucht hat und mich angeschaut hat böse, den Ball verpasst, wodurch wir verloren haben. Das fasst ein ganz guter Spiel zusammen, wir haben uns toll angeschrien. Ich habe einmal, also die Sache ist ja immer, es fing ja schon bei den Aufschlägen an. Und jetzt jemand, der nicht so viele Aufschläge in seinem Leben schon gemacht hat wie du, ich ja auch nicht, jetzt beim Paddel, beim Tennis schon, Paddel habe ich mich auch sehr oft vertan und woanders hingeschlagen, als ich eigentlich wollte. Und irgendwann war so ein bisschen Druck auf deinen Auflegen drauf, weil es ist schon der eine oder andere Doppelfeder passiert. Und wir lagen hinten und dann gebe ich jetzt auch rückblickend, ich habe noch länger darüber nachgedacht, gebe ich zu, ich war ein bisschen zu hart. Du warst sehr fordernd auf jeden Fall als Teamkollegin. Ich habe gedroht. Das andere Team immer Brofist, immer abschlagen, auch wenn der Ball mal nach neben ging, immer sagen, ach wir machen es nur aus Spaß, die pushen sich gegenseitig und du hast mich wirklich in den Boden gerammt mit harscher Kritik, aber hat auch Spaß gemacht. Ich glaube, ich möchte auch ein bisschen Fehler eingestehen. Mein Problem war, ich habe mich auf Paddel vorbereitet, indem ich die Best-of-Compilations von den besten Paddelspielern der Welt gesehen hatte.
Dadurch hatte ich das Bild von Paddel im Kopf, dass das sehr, sehr viele Trickshots, Kunststücke, rausrennen, flinkflak, gerade noch den Ball kriegen. Und ich habe das normale Paddel nie kennengelernt. Ich habe immer nur die oberen ein Prozent der ein Prozent kennenlernen. Ich finde es gar nicht so schlecht, also du hast ja prinzipiell recht, sich auf eine Sportart vorbereiten und das Gucken ist ja eigentlich eine gute Vorbereitung. Ich glaube, es ist Padel einer der wenigen Sportarten, die ganz anders aussehen, je besser ein Padel-Team ist. Ja, zum Beispiel mit Profisport, da hast du aufregende Ballwechsel, irgendwie interessante Strategien. Bei uns war es halt primär so, dass wir dem Ball hinterhergelaufen sind, den wir aus dem Feld rausgeschossen haben. Das sieht man halt selten, wie man das macht. Und auch wenn man auf gegnerische Feld läuft und sagt,
sorry, ihr habt noch einen Ball von uns.
Und dann war da so eine Gruppe Mädels,
die gesagt haben, ja, und dann haben sie alle
Bälle durchgesucht und dann haben wir nach
zehn Minuten den gefunden, den wir wollten.
Das sieht man dann nicht bei YouTube.
Aber mal ganz kurz,
wie lame ist es denn, dass man Paddel
mit einem Tennisball spielt?
Nee, das war ja kein Tennisball.
Es war ein weicherer Bälle. Ja, mein Gott, aber es war im Grunde ein Tennisball. Ich meine, du kannst doch nicht, das ist doch Quatsch, das ist wie wenn du Fussball mit einem Volleyball spielst. Jede Sportart braucht ihren eigenen Ball. Es gibt keine zwei Sportarten, wo du denselben Ball benutzt. Du spielst auch nicht Polo mit einem Baseball. Du hast halt einen leicht anderen Ball. Jede Sportart verdient ihren eigenen Ball. Das ist Quatsch, das kannst du nicht machen. Das Medizin hat ihren eigenen Ball. Ja, jeder hat einen eigenen Ball. Du kannst selbst Erdkundelehrer haben, diesen rot-grünen Ball. Jeder hat seinen Ball. Jeder hat seinen Ball. Jeder hat seinen Ball, außer Paddel. Die haben den Tennisball, mussten sich klauen. Wait, wait, wait. Ich bin noch nicht andersweise weg von diesem Gag. Erdkundelehrer haben rot-grünen Ball. Den grün-blauen Ball, den Globus. Okay, ja, gar nicht. Ich dachte nämlich, dass das der Gag war, aber sehr guter Gag. Dankeschön. Wir haben es gespielt, wir haben richtig Spaß gehabt. Ja. Ich bin teilweise aus der Haut gefahren, das tut mir leid, rückblickend. Ich habe einmal gesagt, wenn du den Aufschlag nicht versenkst, dann tüde ich deine Familie, glaube ich.
Solche Sätze sind gefallen, dafür möchte ich mich rückblickend distanzieren und sagen, ich nehme mich diese Problems an. Ich weiß, ich habe ein Problem. Aber es war wild, ich meine, wir waren draußen. Was du mir nicht gesagt hast, ist, dass die beiden Jungs, gegen die wir spielen werden, von der Sportuni kommen und irgendwie mal Sport studiert haben und ultra krass sind. Das hast du vergessen zu erwähnen, nicht so wild. Und es lag ein totes Eichhörnchen neben dem Spielfeld. Also da weint man erstmal, man ist in der Natur, das sieht man halt nicht im Fernsehen. Das ist halt einfach ein Kadaver eines Eichhörnchens, das in irgendeiner Weise gestorben ist, sodass es direkt neben dem Paddelplatz lag. Ist es vom Baum gefallen? Wurde es von einem Paddelball kaputtgeschlagen? Wurde es kurz mit dem Tennisball verwechselt und totgeschlagen? Oder hat es sich so gefreut, diese Sportart zu entdecken, dass es an einem Herzinfarkt oder so gestorben ist? Das kann auch sein. Kriegen Tiere denn Herzinfarkte? Mhm. Ganz kleine Herzinfarkte. Das ist eine Ameise, wenn die irgendwas sieht, was sie nicht verkraften kann einfach und dann ist es einfach aus? Ich dachte Infarkt, aber das klingt so explosiv, dass dann irgendwas passiert, dass es so eine kleine Explosion gibt im Körper. Ich habe letztens mal wieder in die Glotze geschaut, auch mal wieder angeknipst und ein bisschen gesappt und ich habe mich einfach gefühlt wie ein Zeitreisender. Ja, das spricht auch so. So ein Relikt aus alter Zeit. Das ist so, wie wenn jemand sagt, ich war letztens wieder im Aquädukt und man ist so, ich habe hier keine Ich bin mit einem Pater Noster ins Aquädukt gefahren. Genau. Und so habe ich einfach wieder die Röhre angeschmissen und ein bisschen durchgesappt und habe Werbung gesehen und mir ist eingefallen, dass ich Werbung gesehen habe, die mich damals schon als Kind verwirrt hat, als ich noch ferngeschaut habe, und zwar Werbung gegen Sodbrennen. Und ich habe mir immer gedacht, ich habe nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung, was Sodbrennen ist. Ich erinnere mich noch an das Gespräch mit meinem Vater, wo ich gefragt habe, was ist Sodbrennen? Und ich habe es so angekündigt, als ob mein Vater dachte, jetzt dachte, jetzt kommt das Gespräch. Weil ich so, aber ich muss immer was fragen. Jetzt will er es wissen. Ich habe es im Fernsehen gesehen und da gibt es die ganze Zeit so, ja, gibt es oft in Werbung und so. Mein Junge, ich wusste, dass dieser Moment irgendwann kommt. Setz dich mal zu mir aufs Knie. Nee, es geht eigentlich ganz schnell. Ich wollte mal fragen, aufs Knie. Ich bin auch zu alt, wenn ich diese Frage stellen will, dann bin ich auch zu alt, dafür aufs Knie zu gehen. Ich lasse mich neben dir auf die Couch, okay? Ja, setz dich auf die Couch. Ja. Okay. Was ist Sodbrennen? Ach Gott, verdammt, du bist über 20, mein Sohn! Und du wolltest, dass ich auf deinen Scho setze! Weil mich denkt mir, es gibt ja anscheinend Tabletten gegen Sodbrennen. Vielleicht habe ich Sodbrennen und leide unnötigerweise. Nimm die doch mal. Leide ich, also das ist einfach so. Ich glaube, bei mir fängt es ein. Es gibt ja Shows, wo die, die sind so krass, die nehmen am Anfang der Show Viagra und so, und dann nehmen die den Podcast auf und gucken mal, was passiert. Es gibt so krasse, so weirde Podcasts, wo die Drogen nehmen und gucken, was passiert während der Show. Wir nehmen, weil wir krasse Jungs sind, Tabletten gegen Sodbrennen. Nächste Folge, am Anfang der Folge, ich bringe die mit. Ich treibe hier in Köln, ich will das richtig hin, treibe ich so eine Packung. Boah, Alter, pass auf, pass auf, in welche Kreise du dich da bewegst. Ich weiss noch nicht wie, aber ich glaube, ich kriege das hin über Johnny. Vielleicht komme ich an. Wir fragen mal Randy, ich habe es in E-Mail. Wir schreiben mal Randy, ob uns Randy ein paar Tabletten besorgen kann. Vielleicht können Randy und Johnny so ein Crew zusammenstellen, dass wir an Tabletten gegen Sodbrennen kommen. Und dann können wir die nächste Folge mal nehmen und gucken, ob es besser geht nach der Folge. Ich glaube, mein Problem geht schon da los, dass ich noch nicht genau weiß, was Sod ist. Also Brennen, Sod, ist das eine Abkürzung, Sod, Säure oder Doth oder ich weiß es nicht genau. Superordinärer Dampf. Kann auch sein, ja. Und ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung. Es kann sein, also vielleicht gibt es da diesen Schmerz, den ich regelmäßig spüre, wo normale Leute sagen, ah, Sodbrennen, blub, gehoben. Aber ich ertrage es einfach, keine Ahnung. Ich versuche mal was, ich nehme mal Anlauf und versuche mal was, okay? Hau mal rein. Es ist nicht einfach ein Stefan Tietze an der Theorierampe. Er macht sich warm, die ersten zwei Versuche leider komplett übertreten, das ist sein letzter Versuch. Überhaupt die letzten acht Jahre weiter nehmen. Das ist mein acht Jahre weiter nehmen. Ich sage auch vorher, kann ich das Mikrofon haben? Hi, eigentlich nicht. Und zwar, ich beende meine Karriere, wenn das nicht klappt. Ich beende meine Karriere als Theorie-Jumper, okay? Sie haben es gehört, Stefan Tietze, der einzige Vertreter von Costa Rica, die letzten zehn Jahre als einziger Vertreter seines Landes angetreten. Jetzt der dritte Versuch an der Theorie-Rampe. Ist rotbrennend nicht einfach eine Übersäuerung der Speiseröhre? Und er ist gestürzt! Er ist gestürzt! Aber er rappelt sich auf, weil... Tränen! Tränen! Hören Sie auf, Ding zu bau. Ach nee, Entschuldigung, das ist schon klar, dass ihr Sport wenig reißerisch ist und es nicht häufig häufig auf die Bildet Titel sein ist. Er schmeisst seine Ausrüstung auf den Boden. Hören Sie auf, Ding zu baupen. Er tritt in den Sand. Ganz eigentlich, wenn du als Radiokommentator einen Sport begleitest, auf die eben scheiß Ausdingen einfach, vor allem auch immer so, in seinen Augen spiegelt sich die Enttäuschung der letzten drei Niederlagen und einfach gröselt einfach so, mir geht's gut, ich bin Multimillionär, mir ist es scheißegal, ob ich die treffe da nicht.
Die hören sich auch immer, natürlich.
Aber auch dann so ein Schnitt, wenn man so im Sinne von Roman Weidenfeld an den Augen spiegelt sich der Hass auf den Mitspieler, der ihm schon so viele Tore reingeballert hat oder wie reden.
Und dann schnitt zu ihm und er ist einfach so einen Kilometer weit weg. Ist ja nicht so, dass sie sich erkennen. Also der Kommentare sitzt ja sehr weit weg. Sieht nur so 22 Punkte auf dem Grün einfach. Aber das stimmt. Bundesligaspiele im Radio sind eher lame. Also so lame, wie die Spiele auch im Fernsehen sind. Aber du lernst ja die... Eine Giraffe läuft aufs Feld. Nein, sie hat vier Beine. Sie ist technisch krötznah wahnsinnig überlegen. Sie drümmelt ihn aus. Kopfball im Strafraum! Sind Giraffen die besten Fussballspieler der Welt? Vier Beine und langer Hals. Super im Kopfball, Kopfballstark. Ich weiß nicht, ob mehr Beine helfen. Klar, du kannst dich ja auf die Hinterbeine stellen, aber das ist an Hand. Das weiss man eh nicht. Wir haben auch vier Beine. Sind bei vierbeinigen Tieren die beiden vorderen die Arme oder haben die vier Beine oder haben die zwei Arme und zwei Beine? Ich dachte, ich hätte eine Antwort gehabt, aber dann kam Affen. Und Affen haben handförmige Füße. Sie haben ihre Karriere der Theorie beendet. Gehen Sie nach Hause. Gehen Sie nach Hause. Handförmige Füße. Ich habe sie mir mit meinen eigenen Augen gesehen. Affen haben handförmige Füße. Die können mir den Füssen Thumbs Up zeigen. Oder Give Me Five. Toe Up. Toe Up. Toes Up. Finde ich nicht schlecht. Ich habe letztens einen Ultraschall von einem Fuss gesehen und mir gedacht, das ist eine Hand.
Das ist eine lange Hand.
Ne?
Ich weiß vor allem, du kannst ja bei deinem Fuss nur die Zehen bewegen.
Das ist ja so, als wenn du bei deiner Hand nur die vordersten Glieder deiner Finger bewegen könntest.
Irgendwann konnten wir mal alle bewegen.
Wir stammen ja auch gemeinhin vom Affen ab.
Ich weiß nicht, wenn meine Karriere beenden, aber ich glaube,
ich neige mich langsam Fakten zu, einfach.
Jetzt kommen wieder hundert Kommentare,
die sagen, nein, der Mensch stammt
nicht vom Affen ab, sondern der Mensch
und der Affe haben denselben Vorfahren.
Ja, das meint man, wenn man sagt,
Mensch stammt vom Affen ab, ey.
Warum meint man eigentlich, bei Podcasts
immer alles wörtlich zu nehmen? Jesus Christ, ey. Immer derselbe Kommentar. Aber bei Podcasts immer alles immer wörtlich. Aber seid ihr auch so im echten Leben? Sind die auch so im echten Leben, dass die immer solche Nutzerkommentare schreiben? Ich glaube, das sind die Protokollleser. Wir geben ja immer ein Transkript raus von der Folge. Und ich glaube, die lesen die Folge einfach komplett. Die lesen es gegen. Die lesen es gegen und ich glaube, da kommen oft so die ironischen Untertöne nicht so ganz gut durch. Dabei schreibe ich extra immer, Florentin, ironische Unterton, Klammer zu, Menschen stammen vom Affen ab. Ja, und dann sagen die, worauf bezieht sich das? Ist das trotzdem faktisch? Das ist schwierig. Aber spart euch den Kommentar, wir wissen, was ihr meint. Aber ich finde die Idee sehr, sehr gut, die du gerade gesagt hast, die leider so ein bisschen untergegangen ist, die tatsächlich, ich würde dir eine Wertung von zehn geben, die Idee, die du hattest, aber wird wahrscheinlich nie umgesetzt, ist halt schwierig. Aber ich finde die Idee super, ich finde die Idee richtig gut und ich glaube, die könnte nochmal echt alles verändern. Ja, ich glaube, es könnte wirklich alles verändern. Ich glaube, das würde aus dem Planeten nachhaltig bessere Planeten machen. Wieso Planeten jetzt? Ich meinte für den Fussball. Ach so, okay. Weil du ja meintest, wäre es nicht geil. Ich bin auch gegangen. Ich dachte, ich bin immer für irgendeine Theorie und ich habe grob was gesucht, was einigermaßen auch zu allen passt. Es hat nichts im Fussball, es war zu gross für Fussball. Die Idee, weil du meinst ja, wäre es nicht ultra stark, wenn man einfach die verkabeln würde, die Fussballspieler, wenn man einfach hört, was die sagen. Weil das ist ja geil. Ich bin ja zum Beispiel großer Fan von Dota, E-Sport, da gibt es immer eine Dokumentation, wo die Spieler verkabelt sind und man hört, was die sagen während des Spiels. Und es ist ultra interessant mitzukriegen, was die denken, was deren Priorität gerade ist, worüber die reden. Weil natürlich gibt es auch Kommentatoren, aber die haben natürlich nochmal einen anderen Blick aufs Spiel als die Spieler selber. Und wie geil wäre es denn, wenn einfach generell, weil ich meine, die Mikrofone werden immer kleiner und immer kleiner und immer kleiner. Teilweise so klein, dass sie verloren werden regelmäßig, was ein Problem ist. Du musst dann nämlich wieder größere Mikrofone, größere Detektoren bauen, die die wieder finden. Und die Detektoren werden halt auch immer kleiner mit der Zeit in technischen Vorträgen. Das ist ein Problem, wohingegen Handys immer wieder immer größer werden. Die werden immer größer. In beide Richtungen geht es ins Extrem. Und du kannst doch mittlerweile den einfach irgendwie so einen kleinen Knips hinmachen ans Trikot. So wirklich so winzig klein. Du siehst es nicht, macht keinen Unterschied. Und dann einfach die mitschneiden, was die Fussballer so sagen. Ja, ich glaube, die wollen das nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Warum nicht? Ja, die machen ja schon, hast du die mal nach dem Spielfeld, wenn die reden, machen die schon den hier. Seht ihr jetzt nicht? Ich mache meine Hand nämlich vor den Mund, muschelförmig, weil die nicht sehen wollen, was man sagt. Weil Lippenleser am Start. Weil das ganze Zeit voller Lippenleser ist. Ja, das ist voller Lippenleser. Die meisten Ticketverkäufe gehen heute tatsächlich an Lippenleser bei Bundesligaspielen, die einfach nur drauf gucken, was sie sagen. Aber ist das denn so geheim?
Haben die dann wie so beim Football dann so
24 Toast 45?
Das ist Privatsphäre, die wollen einfach nicht,
wie geht es dann einer Frau, wie geht es dann
den Kindern, ich hoffe, heute war echt
schwieriges Spiel. Und da kommt der Ball und
die haben jetzt eine neue
Espresso-Maschine und
ich meine nicht nach dem Spiel.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch ist, bei den Siebträgern, aber bei mir ist das immer so... Also, nach dem Spiel nicht mal ein Werbenspiel. Also, ist das auch mal wirklich, fluchen die, wenn die aus Versehen dagegen treten, oder sagen die, ah, beim nächsten Mal treffe ich bestimmt. So jetzt, ich neige immer wieder zu einer Theorie, aber ich habe ein Video schon gesehen, wo der Schiedsrichter verkabelt wurde, und das war ein absolutes Meisterwerk, dieses Video. Ich meine, Manuel Gräfer wurde verkabelt. Und das ist der Ton, der da herrscht. Rau, rau, rau. Ja, muss man aber. Man muss teilweise mit diesen Profisperren auch hart ins Gericht gehen, sage ich immer wieder. Ja, genau. Die verdienen auch so viel Geld und die sind auch so ein bisschen, denen steigt das zu Kopf. Aber der Manuel Gräfer, der hat das raus, wie er mit hinspricht. Und ich meine, es gibt doch das Meme Radio Müller, weil er so viel redet, weil Thomas Müller so viel redet. Wurde er nicht auch mal verkabelt oder? Ich finde es eine starke Idee, es geht schon in die Richtung, ich glaube, die Leute setzen deine Idee langsam, aber sicher um, generell alle verkabeln. Ich will alles verkabelt haben, ich will jedes Tier in der Tierdoku, ich will, dass das Tier ein kle Ansteck-Mikrofon hat, einfach um zu wissen, was die reden. Kennst du den Trick mit deinen Airpods, mit deinen Apple Airpods? Ah ja gut, das ist gemein. Hast du das schon mal gemacht, da jemanden spioniert? Okay, ich hätte ja nicht gedacht, dass jemand, der mir vorher sagt, ich will jetzt alles verkabeln, dass der mir dann mit meinem Airpod-Trick in den Rücken fällt. Nein, da muss schon jemand kommen und dir so am Hals rumgrabbelnangenehm, und das Mikrofon anstecken, damit du weißt, dass du es kamst. Du kannst ihm am Hals rumgrabbeln und legst dein Handy da hinten. Das ist nicht gemein. Das hört es für dich auf. Ja, da ist mit Datenschutz dann auch wichtig. Das ist ein ganz schmaler Grat, hast du. Und du hast wie so eine, deine Grenze verläuft nicht so wie die amerikanischen Grenzen, sondern eher wie so alte europäische Grenzen. So ein bisschen undurchsichtig. Wo in dem Land noch ein Teil des Nachbarlands ist, wie so ein See innen drin, wo noch so ein kleiner Enklave ist. Ja, so ein kleiner Inselstaat an, wo Datenschutz wichtig ist. Ja, wo wenn du zehn Kilometer reist, du dich durch vierunddreißig Länder bewegst, einfach ständig Grenze, Grenze, Grenze. Und viele Minenfelder. Ja, ich sag mal, ein guter Kontinent ist aufgebaut wie ein Baumkuchen. Du hast viele schöne Schichten, ganz viele Ringe. Gibt's ringförmige Länder? Ganz viele Ringe. Für mich, für manchmal gibt's zu wenig richtig ringförmige Donutländer. Wäre das nicht das beste Land? Weil ich meine, der Globus ist ja eine Kugel, im weitesten Sinne. Das heißt, die Ringform ist ja ohnehin schon mal angelegt, natürlich. Das heißt, wir Menschen sollten das aufgreifen, finde ich, meine Meinung. Müsst mich ja nicht wählen. Also bitte, aber muss nicht sein. So, und jetzt sagt man einfach, wir teilen, weil die Länge und Breitengrade, finde ich, haben hier schon Riesenschritte gemacht, haben gesagt, wir teilen die Erde in Kreise auf. Jetzt einfach sagen, jedes Land kriegt einen Kreis. Das ist ja ideal. Also jedes Land hat alle Zeitzonen, auch mega praktisch. Ja, mega praktisch. Wenn du keinen Bock hast, früh aufzustehen, ziehst du in einen anderen Bereich des Landes, kann das später aufstehen. Du kannst auch jetzt in einen anderen Bereich des Landes ziehen. Ja, aber ein anderes Land, andere Sitten, da gibt es dann der Joghurt. Andere Länder, andere Sitten, das sagt man, das sagt man. Ja, da kommt das her. Da gibt es dann irgendwie einen komischen Joghurt, nicht mehr den Pudding, den du gerne magst, gibt es dann nicht mehr und so. Und so, gut für Jogger, kannst du einmal um die ganze Welt joggen, einfach immer geradeaus. Das ist so gut für Jogger. Perfekt, Leute, die gerne Fahrrad fahren, perfekt. Das grösste Problem für Jogger sind ja, wissen ja alle, Landesgrenzen. Wenn mal wirklich heute Abend mal wirklich eine große Runde drehen, Du meinst durch Luxemburg? Vergiss deinen Pass nicht, Schatz.
Vergiss deinen Pass nicht, ach ja.
Oh nein, die Vignette.
Die Vignette muss ich mir aufklären.
Du kriegst auf die Stirn so eine Vignette geballert.
Aber da merkt man es.
Ich glaube, unser Paddelspiel war das erste Mal, dass ich Sport gemacht habe.
Das war wirklich zehn Jahre.
Also wirklich zehn Jahre.
Hat man dir?
Nicht angemerkt.
Das ist nett, aber es ist wirklich schon so
auch dieses Gefühl, so du gehst da hin,
hast deinen Turnbeutel dabei.
Allein so eine Turntasche zu packen.
Und du weißt nicht, was tue ich da rein, zwei
Pinguine, drei Milchschnitten, brauche
ich neue Schuhe, brauche ich irgendwie besondere
Strümpfe, kann ich mein Snoopy-T-Shirt anziehen
oder haben die alle so coole Trikots an,
muss ich mir die Brustwarzen abkleben,
ja, musste ich beim Joggen oft machen, als ich früher gejoggt habe, musste ich mir die Brustwarzen abkleben. Machen das alle Jogger oder ist das dein Problem gewesen? Ich weiß es nicht, ich glaube, das ist ein Thema, man spricht nicht viel über Brustwarzen. Oder hätte es aber den Kettenhemden nicht anziehen sollen. Aber ich muss trainieren für den grossen Kreuzzug, Stefan, wann denn sonst? Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, Brustwarzen ist ein Thema, das zu selten vorkommt im aktuellen Diskurs. Und ich glaube, es ist verlacht, aber extrem schmerzvoll. Vor allem ist es ja ein Teufelskreis. Die tun weh, werden härter, dadurch reiben die noch mehr am T-Shirt, werden noch härter und in unendliche Längen können die gehen. Also wirklich, das ist unfassbar, was da teilweise noch in der Brust teilweise für Tiefen herrscht. Du fährst so Dornen aus, so Triceratops-artige Dornen. Ja, das ist ja der Mensch, stammt ja vom Triceratops ab und die Hörner haben sich zurück. Und jetzt kommen ja die Nachrichten, nein, grob, grob. Ihr wisst doch, was wir meinen. Und deswegen muss man da echt aufpassen, deswegen habe ich immer schön abgeklebt. Dadurch habe ich auch, falls ihr mich mal nackt seht, bitte nicht erschrecken, ich habe um meine Brustwarzen herum keine Haare. Weil dadurch, dass ich das immer abgeklebt habe, wurde es automatisch enthaart, weil ich habe dann also ein Klebeband. Und dann haben die Haare immer gesagt, da wachst du jetzt nicht mehr nach. Du hast keinen Bock mehr. Das heißt, ich habe wirklich wie so ein Kranz, wie so ein Land eigentlich quasi, wie so ein kleines Land um die Brustwarze herum, wo keine Haare sind, was ein durchaus verstörender Anblick ist, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Mich stören meine Haare um meine Brustwarze. Ja. Und ich rasiere mir die manchmal weg. Mit einem trocken, nass oder trocken? Möchte ich nicht sagen. Will ich nicht darauf, nee, schon trocken. Aber hast du Angst, dass du deine Brustwarze abrasierst? Nee, ich bin ganz vorsichtig. Ich bin ganz vorsichtig beim Abrasieren der Haare um meine Brustwarzen herum. Ja. Aber habe ich nicht so gerne. Ich finde es sieht komisch aus. Aber ab wann machst du da einen Übergang? Hast du da so einen Gradienten oder ist das einfach ein harter Cut? Nee, schon so epizentrumartig. Weißt du, geht so langsam, sonst feit. Aber wie machst du das? Wie machst du denn Fade? Ja, Arbeit, viel Arbeit, ehrlich gesagt. Stundenlang sitzt du dann da, um das perfekt zu machen. Ja, und man kann dabei auch nichts machen, weil es ja laut ist, ja Du hast dann immer so verschiedene Längen bei deinem Schneider und machst dann... Ja, aber ich bin ja nicht so päpstlich jetzt unterwegs, ich bin zumindest nicht päpstlicher als der Papst unterwegs. Ja, nee, das geht nicht. Das geht ja gar nicht klar. Und es kommen nicht acht Längen zum Einsatz, sondern eher drei. Okay, drei Stufen Gradient, okay. Genau. Ja, warum nicht? Nee, aber es hat mich gestört. Aber ich weiß auch nicht. Warum stört dich daran? Haare, die sehen in der Nähe von diesen Brustwarzen, sehen die komischer aus, finde ich. Also ich mag diesen Anblick nicht. Ich finde, das sieht ungepflegt aus. Aber es ist auch mein Ding. Also es kann jemanden wieder will. Es ist auch nicht richtig, was ich sage, vielleicht. Also sehr wahrscheinlich nicht. Das ist ja ein ethisches Urteil. Das ist ja meine Meinung. Ja. Und ich will jetzt nicht irgendwie, also wenn die GQ oder die Men's Health das anders sieht, ist es ja okay. Aber es ist meine Meinung. Falls sie mich nächste Ausgabe. Falls ihr mich eigentlich mal interviewen wollt für die nächste Ausgabe. Also falls ihr mich erreichen würden unter deiner E-Mail-Adresse. Unter deiner E-Mail-Adresse stefan.tiese at menshealth.com. Richtig, ich habe schon mal einfach mich bei euch eingeschleust, damit der Weg der Mail nicht so weit ist. Damit ihr nicht so lange braucht. Clever. Gute Idee. Finde ich eine richtig gute Idee. Ich habe immer häufiger das Gefühl, dass Leute meine E-Mail-Adresse erraten. Oh ja. Entweder das... Eine E-Mail-Adresse ist sehr offensichtlich. Oder es geht jemand da draußen rum und verteilt die wie Visitenkarten. Ja, ich habe letztens hier am Heumarkt war einer, der hatte so Flyer dabei. Da stand einfach deine E-Mail-Adresse drauf. Irgendwas anderes noch. Nein, gar nichts. Dann ist es okay, ehrlich gesagt. Nur deine E-Mail-Adresse, ich will sie jetzt hier nicht nennen, müsst ihr euch schon selber so einen Wisch holen, aber tatsächlich den ganzen Tag ausgeteilt. Ich wünschte, ich hätte gefragt, warum eine Person das macht. Aber man kommt dann auf die richtigen Fragen, kommt man da manchmal nicht. Nee, man guckt ja da immer, man nimmt das und weiß genau, man wirft es gleich wieder weg und dann habe ich auch mal geguckt. Das hat mir nicht gefragt, warum er meine E-Mail-Adresse ohne sämtliche andere Informationen verteilt. Ich habe vergessen nachzufragen, leider. Das war, das war, da habe ich kurz einen Aussetzer. Das ist ein richtiger Aussetzer. Ein richtiger Aussetzer, leider. Tut mir leid. Ich hoffe, ich werde deswegen nicht von der Polizei verhört, vor Gericht oder so. Und er sagt, Moment mal, Sie haben jemanden mit einem blutigen Messer in der Hand an Ihnen vorbeilaufen sind und Sie haben nicht die Polizei informiert. Nee, sorry. Genau wie ich gestern meinen Nachbarn getroffen habe, der die neuen Nachbarn getroffen hat. Und man muss sich das vorstellen, es sind so halb Gewerbetreibende in meinem Haus und halb Privatwohnungen und so, aber da wurde jetzt eine Gewerbeeinheit, wurde verkauft. und mein Nachbar hat den neuen Eigentümer getroffen. Und da hat mein Nachbar mir erzählt, dass er sehr lange mit ihm gesprochen hat. Und meine erste Frage an meinen Nachbarn war, ja, was bauen die jetzt da rein? Und er hat gesagt, das habe ich jetzt nicht gefragt. Das stimmt, da hatte ich ihm einen Aufsitzer, das habe ich jetzt nicht gefragt. Ich glaube, du bist gut im Nachfragen, du bist echt ein Borner Journalist, du triffst die Leute immer da, wo sie nicht vorbereitet sind. Du hast diese einzigartige Gabe. Ja, aber sorry, ich will doch wissen, was mein direkter Nachbar plant, da reinzubauen bei sich. Er meinte irgendwas, glaube ich, so ein Presslufthammer-Testzentrum oder irgendwie sowas. Oder das oder ein Nachtclub. Ich bin eins von beiden, ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher. Ja, das war so eine Kinderhort, wo man ganz laute Kinder abgeben kann, die zu nervig sind für ihre Eltern, kann man da abgeben. Die lauten. Die ganz lauten, die besonders lauten. Je jünger, desto lauter, sagt man ja oft. Und die sind richtig jung. Also richtig, richtig jung. Gestern wurde ich kurz aufgeschrocken von Lärm von draußen. Ich habe ja oft Lärm von draußen, ich wohne ja an einer viel benutzten Straße von verschiedenen Dingen. Aufgeweckt von einer Demonstration, Demo, Pauken, Trompeten, Bannerfahnen, Standarten. Laute Banner, so richtig laute. Richtig grelle Banner, wo du wirklich mal aus dem Fenster guckst und sagst, wow. Das ist nicht transparent, das ist schon Banner. Banner und Inhalt der Demo war Belarus, ein Land in Europa. Und ich habe nicht ganz verstanden, was ich jetzt machen soll. Ich habe mir da natürlich die Folge Last Week Tonight angeschaut, wo es um den Diktator von Belarus geht, aber diese Demo hat mich fragend zurückgelassen. Warst du schon mal auf einer Demo und oder hat eine Demo schon mal bei dir Wirkung gezeigt? Ja, ich war schon mal auf Demos, bei Demos, wo ich hinter dem Sinn und Zweck der Demo stand und bin dann da mitgelaufen. Aber du bist so leicht zu begeistern, dass du direkt auf die Gegendemo übergelaufen bist. Es kann durchaus passieren. Es ist erst drei, vier Mal vollkommen. Aber dass die Gegendemo mich auch überzeugt. Ich hätte es oft, dass ich dann immer sage, ich gehe jetzt mal zu denen hin und versuche, mit denen zu reden. Dann höre ich mit deren Seite an. Das ist wie so eine gute True-Crime-Doku, wo die eine Folge irgendwie den und den zum Suspekt hat, die andere Folge ist dann sie der Suspekt und so. Und ich bin halt sehr wankelmütig und sehr leicht zu begeistern und sehr leicht zu überzeugen. Und dann wollte ich die konfrontieren mit ihrer Meinung und so, dann haben die mich aber sehr schnell überzeugt. Es kommt wahrscheinlich bei Demos auch oft vor, dass man aus Versehen auf der falschen Demo ist. Also das sagen sie, nie damit Belarus, nie damit, und dann neben dir tippt ich an, nee, nee, du, wir sind für. Ach scheiße, für. Darum ging's, für oder gegen Belarus? Naja. Was so grundsätzlich? Wie grundsätzlich sind Demos heutzutage noch? Das ist die Frage so, und die Frage ist, also ich frage mich ja immer, okay, diese Demo hat mich erreicht, literally, sie war direkt vor meiner Tür, was kann ich jetzt tun, was ist jetzt meine
Aufgabe? Haben Sie mir Richtung deines Fensters geschrien oder warum sagst du, sie hat sich
erreicht? Ja, was heißt Demo, sie standen vor meinem Fenster und haben in mein Fenster gerufen, bis ich die
Rollos runtergemacht habe. Ja, weil du diese Belarus-Flagge da seit Tagen raushängst. Ich dachte mir, erst mal tolle
Farben, rot-weiß, schöne Farben und sie haben aber auch auf belarussisch sich geäußert. Das heißt, mehrere Kommunikationshürden standen uns im Weg. Erst mal, sie zogen an mir vorbei. Ich konnte keine Nachfragen stellen. Jetzt auch mal so no offense und so. Und auch gut, dass Leute für ihre Meinung auf die Strasse gehen. Ja, scheiß auf Belarus. Nee, aber ganz im Ernst. Sorry. Ich dachte, du willst... Warum in in Köln muss man doch jetzt nicht ... Ja, gut, ich meine, es sind vielleicht Belarusen, die in Köln leben und sagen, hey, unser Heimatland ist unter der Diktatur irgendwie, da wird Wahlbetrug, da werden Journalisten eingesperrt, die Opposition wird unterdrückt, all diese Sachen halt. Lass uns was dagegen machen. Ich habe dann, es gibt von Last Week Tonight, die verkaufen Teddybären, die man halt kaufen kann und dann geht es zur Hilfe von Belarus. Also falls ihr Belarus helfen wollt, könnt ihr ein Teddybär kaufen und oder ich weiß auch nicht genau was. Das ist das Problem. Diese Demo hat mich ein bisschen zurückgelassen. Ich habe immer, als ich in Berlin gewohnt habe, habe ich in der Nähe der nordkoreanischen Botschaft gelebt. Und da war fast ständig Demonstrationen vor der nordkoreanischen Botschaft, gegen Arbeitslager,
für Menschenrechte und so.
Und ich mir auch dachte, ja, kommt das irgendwo an?
Also nimmt der einen Hörer in die Hand und sagt, hier sind zwölf Rentner vor der Botschaft,
die finden irgendwie unser menschenverachtendes Regime schlecht.
Und da eine andere Leitung, nein!
Oh ne, dann... Was? Wie viele? Zwölf Rentner. Viele Jaguar-Skin-Jacken. Viele Sandalen. Und hast du denen erklärt, warum wir es machen? Weil wir eine ganz andere Ideologie haben und wo ganz anders herkommen? Ja genau, wo ganz anders herkommen und halt auch keinen freien Willen haben, weil wir in der Direktur leben, habe ich versucht, ihn zu erklären. Hast du dir das erklärt? Ja,, habe ich versucht, zu erklären. Wir sind immer noch dagegen. Wir sind immer noch dagegen, ja. Die wollen Menschenrechte. Vielleicht ist es Zeit, dass wir das einfach lassen. Meinst du? Ja, weil es ist schon menschenverachtend. Ich meine, die haben einen Punkt. Die haben wirklich einen Punkt. Ganz so cool ist die Idee nicht, dass einer... Nies nochmal zwei Plakate vor, bitte. Vielleicht auch noch ein paar gute Argumente. Also hier steht, wir wollen Menschenrechte jetzt, Diktatur auf Lebenszeit und der Sohn macht danach weiter, ist keine gute Idee, weil schaut euch mal eure eigenen Kinder an, was für Vollidioten es sind, wollt ihr wirklich, dass so jemand dann danach die Herrschaft über das Land hat?
Das steht wo drauf?
Das steht auf einem der grösseren Plakate.
Auf seinem grösseren Plakat.
Kein schlechter Punkt. Ich würde meinem Kind nicht meinen Job einfach so geben. Würdest du einfach sagen, dein Kind kriegt den Job nach dir? Also, dass dein Kind automatisch Botschafter wird. Könntest du damit leben oder würdest du sagen, Gott, der Trottel, der macht gar nichts? Das ist schon ein ziemlicher Depp. Katsch, oder? Dumme Idee. Ich spiele gerade mit seiner nordkoreanischen Version von Nintendo Switch.
Und bei der nordkoreanischen Version von Zelda ist er gerade im nordkoreanischen ersten Level gescheitert.
Ach, gerade. von Nintendo Switch und bei der nordkoreanischen Version von Zelda ist er gerade im nordkoreanischen ersten Level gescheitert. Und ich denke mir, der ist so ein ganz kleiner, dummer Idiot. Er hat nicht mal den ersten Imperialisten besiegen können? Er hat nicht mal den ersten Imperialisten besiegen können. Und dann denke ich mir auch, vielleicht ist er nicht der Richtige, um weiterzumachen. Ja, du, ich muss los, aber so viel von Berlin. Liebe Grüße nach Berlin. Danke. Ich denke mal hier noch bei den Menschenrechten nach. Denk mal drüber nach. Ciao. Und so habt ihr Einfluss auf die Welt. Ja, so passiert das. Demokratie. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, was da passiert. Spread it. Vielleicht sind die auch zur belarussischen Botschaft hingegangen in Köln. Ich weiß nicht, aber ich meine, am selben Tag kam wie gesagt die Folge von Last Week Tonight raus. Die hat auch so ein bisschen meine Aufmerksamkeit geschärft, aber ich bin jetzt dem Problem Belarus gewahr und werde alles in meiner Macht stehende tun, um den Leuten zu helfen. Teddybären kaufen. Ja. Du willst 50 Teddybären kaufen. Heißt Belarus einfach schönes Russland? Teddybär? Oder heißt es, also, Bella hat nichts zu tun mit dem italienischen. So, Belarus ist ja Weissrussland, ne? Haben wir mal früher Weissrussland genannt. Das macht man aber jetzt nicht mehr. Ich habe nicht genau den Switch mitbekommen, aber an irgendeinem Punkt wurde nicht mehr Weissrussland gesagt, sondern Belarus. Leute, ich meine, wir haben so viele Länder, die in Nord und Süd geteilt sind, in Ost und West. Und warum sagt Russland, wir teilen jetzt in Normal und in Weiss? Das ist halt wirklich so dieses Kinder-Bueno-System,
wo du sagst, es gibt das Kinder und normale Bueno und das Bueno White.
Wer baut nach diesem System, nach dem Kindersystem, sein Land auf?
Mach doch Ost-Süd, Ost-West, wie jedes andere Land auch, oder Nieder und Ober.
Nieder und Ober finde ich gut.
Oberlande, Niederlande finde ich sehr gut.
Niedersachsen, Obersachsen.
Ja, Obersachsen ist mein Lieblingsbundesland.
Wo ist fucking Obersachsen?
Ist Obersachsen nicht Rheinland-Pfalz?
So, und jetzt haben wir ein Problem.
Jetzt machen wir eine Demo.
Ja, wir können aber für den Quatsch auf die Strasse gehen.
Das braucht das Land gerade.
Ich habe gerade gedacht, wo du gerade das Bueno gesagt hast, wo man eine Liste machen mit den besten Kinderprodukten. Boah, das ist schwierig. Aber kühl und warm getrennt? Ja, das ist jetzt die große Frage, das ist jetzt die Grätchenfrage. Tatsächlich, ich vermisse immer noch Happy Hippo Snack, gibt es nicht mehr. Oder sitzt durch Hippo Schoko irgendwas. Du meinst aber jetzt nicht, dass die Nilpferde es im Kühlregal lange als Schoko Fresh gab. Du meinst den Happy Hippo Snack, den es gab im normalen Regal. War das die fucking beste Testimonial-Kooperation aller Zeiten? Kinder-Schoko-Fresh mit Eco-Fresh. War das einfach ein Universum kommt zusammen an einem Punkt? Ich meine, die gesamte Timeline der Menschheit, von babylonischen Kriegen, punischer Aufstand, alles. Letztlich nur darauf hinaus, dass Schoko-Fresh und Eco-Fresh zusammen kooperieren. Sie beiden, ist das die beste Marketing-Love-Story aller Zeiten? Ich meine, als der seinen Namen sich gesucht hat, aus dem grossen Buch der Rappernamen und Seite 19 aufgeschlagen hat. Und May I Say nur bis 11 gekommen ist. Ja, hat er nicht daran gedacht, dass Kinder irgendwann, weil das heißt ja wahrscheinlich auch in anderen Ländern Fresh. Das ist ja genial. Das heißt, du musst ja eigentlich heute als Rapper... Ich habe nicht mitbekommen, das entscheidet gerade mein Enthusiasmus
ein bisschen, dass die jemals kooperiert haben.
Ja klar, als es rauskam damals, Ecofresh.
Schokofresh.
Schokofresh mit Ecofresh?
Was kamst du erst raus?
Ich weiß nicht, wer von wem geklaut hat. Aber musst du nicht
heute eigentlich als markenbewusster
Rapper dir schon
bei deinem Namen überlegen, für was
könnte ich mal Werbung machen? Weil Ecofresh, der kann ja nicht Nein sagen. Wenn Schokofresh sagt, wollen sie Werbung machen, Es ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr Sondern die muss so, oder Kinder Schoko Sido, das funktioniert ja gar nicht. So, das heißt, der muss das ja annehmen, weil die sagen, wir können sonst keine Werbung machen, sonst macht es Joko. Und der ist bei Kinder Joko Fresh, der ging auch. Das ging ja auch ganz gut, Kinder Joko Fresh. Nee, aber deswegen bringen die alle ihre eigenen Süßigkeiten raus, die Jokolade zum Beispiel. Ja, stimmt, die sind zu ungeduldig. Wahrscheinlich wollten die unbedingt einen Marketingdeal haben und irgendwann, aber mir hat das Telefon geklinglingelt, saß den ganzen Tag vorm Telefon und hat gesagt, weißt du was, ich mache jetzt meinen eigenen Sidomix, das sind Rosinen, kleine Schokokrossis und dann irgendwie diese Brause, wo man so den Lutscher reindippen kann, so das ist der Sidomix. Mache ich jetzt, bringe ich es raus. Einfach zu ungeduldig, diese Rapper,ys sind so ungeduldig. Wartet doch mal, bis ihr in der Reihe seid.
Jetzt hat der Hafty vielleicht jetzt einen Hafty rausgebracht.
Einen Eis-Tee,
ein Hafty. Finde ich ganz gut.
Und ich könnte literally einmal
den Teeze rausbringen.
Den Teeze, ja. Den Teeze, T-E-A.
Teeze.
Jetzt die allen Tee rausbringen.
Pass auf, ich könnte
sogar rausbringen, fällt mir gerade auf, den Ste-Fan-Tietze. Sch- Ste-Fan-Tietze. Ja, das finde ich richtig gut. Es ist ein bisschen doof, aber es ist halt Tee-Fan-Tietze. Welche Geschmacksrichtung hätte dein Ste-Fan- Tietze? Ich bin dein Purist. Absolute Purist. Kamille. Lemon und Angeboten. Einfach so ein Eistee. Graziell Teller. Nein, es gibt bei mir gibt es es sollte auch nur diese beiden Eistees geben. Lemon und Pfirsich. Die beiden gibt es. Und es soll primär, und ich bin ganz ehrlich, ich will nur Lipton nehmen und umetikettieren. Verstehe. Weil ich finde die schon sehr gut. So 80% Lipton, 20% Aldi. Die Armen Lipton. Trennen die Eistee, einfach ein bisschen mischen. Gehören Lipton zu dem Bösen? Nein, Lipton ist für sich gut. Wahrscheinlichkeit ist hoch, dass die das Wasser irgendjemandem wegnehmen, der es mehr braucht. Keine Ahnung. Weil Lipton tut mir ein bisschen leid, dass die jetzt halt so überrannt werden von Haftis und Tietzes und Brat-Tee und so. Ja, das stimmt. Weil die machen seit Jahren, oder Arizona-Eis, die tut mir auch leid, diese altgedienten Eistee-Marken. Niemand konnte mit dieser Rapper-Flute rechnen, also mit dieser Rapper-Tee-Flute rechnen, das funktioniert nicht. Keine Branche ist sicher vor den Rappern heute. Kann ich mal als Lipton einfach so ein Deutschrap-Album rausbringen? Weißt du was? Pfirsich, Pfirsich, Pfirsich, Pfirsich, Pfirsich. Nichts reinzunehmen. Drei Teile Pfirsich. Gibt es ja bei Snapples. Snapples, amerikanische Eis, die haben wir in New York viel getrunken. Da gibt es Hälfte Zitrone, Hälfte Pfirsich in einer Flasche. So, wir bringen jetzt das Lipton-Album raus und bitte. Hey, du willst erfrischt sein, dann kauf dir einen Lipton. Mega. Hey, willst du erfrischt sein? Ich verspreche mich auch. Ich will mich auch immer versprechen. Wir sind keinem professionellen Rapper, wir sind Tee-Farmer. Ich meine, gib mir eine Woche und du hast den Florenti. Florenti. Florenti Stefan Tietze. Florenti. Aber auch hier die Frage, was macht man da mit dem N? Ja, du musst Florenti einfach sagen. Florenti, aber ich glaube, ich mache ganz exotische Sorten, weil der Eistee von Capital Bra hat ja auch Vanille zum Beispiel. Vanille und Wassermelone und so, finde ich gar nicht schlecht, dass du zu den Klassikern noch so ein bisschen Besondere bringst. Wassermelone ist irre überschätzt. Nein! Irre überschätzt. Schmeckt gar nicht. Viel zu süße Version von Erdbeeren. Kannst du aber auch gut selber machen, gut selber machen, einfach schön Fleisch in einen Mixer und mischen. Warum? Das kommt dir nicht so leicht über die Lippen. Das verrätst du nicht so gerne das Rezept. Ja, weil ich gerade im Hinterkopf hatte, verdammt gebe ich jetzt meinen Geheimnispreis, den ich eigentlich für Florentee bräuchte. Das ist doch eigentlich Marktwirtschaft, wie sie sein sollte. Jeder einzelne Mensch bringt seinen eigenen Eistee raus und dann lass den Markt entscheiden. Dann lass einfach mal am Ü... Mach immer keine Sorgen, der Markt entscheidet schon jetzt. Ich habe eine Idee und zwar gibt es Lavendel-Tee. Oh, jetzt wird es wild. Lavendel-Eistee. Aber willst du Lavendel zur Erfrischung? Weil was du nicht verstehst, was du nicht in deinem kleinen Hirnchen... Zu dumm. Weil du zu dumm bist, nicht verstehst. Lavendel schmeckt auch richtig lecker. Ich habe nämlich neulich in Italien hatte ich Ravioli mit Lavendel drin. Was? Ja, die haben einfach Lavendel als Nahrungsmittel mir untergejubelt. Aber als Hauptzutat? Als Hauptzutat in den Ravioli. Aber einfach so oder in der Sauce? Nee, schon in einer leckeren Sauce. Schon in einer leckeren Tomatensauce? Nee, aber in einer leckeren, sehr dezenten, subtilen Sahnesoße. Aber der Hauptstar, also All-Eyes, rampenlichtvoll auf Lavendel. Du erzählst immer von deinen tollen kulinarischen Erlebnissen und entwickelst dich weiter. Und ich glaube, du isst jetzt besser als vor zehn Jahren. Du kannst kochen, du hast Delikatessen dabei, du beißt Tauben den Kopf ab, du bist einfach angekommen. Ich entwickle mich so hart zurück einfach, so hart. Deswegen habe ich dir jetzt schon mit Johnny und Kevin vorgestellt. Ich nehme mich ja langsam mit in meine Welt, die viel besser geworden ist. Ist das so eine Art Pretty Woman Projekt von mir, dass du mich aufpäppeln willst oder wie und zurück in die Gesellschaft holen willst? Diese Musik,, diese Musik, die die ganze Zeit schon weit entfernt zu hören ist, das ist die Montagemusik. Das ist die längste fucking Montage der Welt. Welche Teile nehmen wir denn? Die wird doch geschnitten, das ist ja Movie Magic. Ja, aber ich dachte nicht, dass die die gesamte Zeit zu Ende ist, weil wir wollen die das so schneiden, wenn du die Musik schon drauf hast im Rohmaterial. Ja, wir haben jetzt schon 379.000 Stunden Material. Ich sag, du kannst sie nicht schneiden. Ich sag, du hast dir da selber ein Bein gestellt.
Weil ich entwickle mich nämlich zurück.
Weil was ich entwickelt habe.
Das ist uns im Schnitt auch aufgefallen.
Was ich entwickelt habe, und zwar du sagst jetzt, oh, Lavendelcreme, super, Tortilla.
Ich habe letztens mir geholt Mr. Max.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob jemand Mr. Max kennt, ich kannte es auch nicht. Und jetzt, du hast gerade von diesen qualitativ hochwertigen Eistees gesprochen. Denk in genau andere Richtung. Denk in exakt die andere Richtung. Du denkst exotische Zutaten, hohe Qualität, anspruchsvolles Design. Denk alles davon 180 Grad zurück. Ich gebe dir ein paar Eckdaten, um dieses Produkt so ein bisschen einzuordnen. Es ist ein Erfrischungsgetränk. Und vielleicht schaffe ich es mit einem einzigen Fakt, dir dieses Produkt klarzumachen. Folgender Fakt. Fünf Liter ein Euro. Love it. Aber was? Der Tietze ist auch nicht ... Fünf Liter, eine Mark. Mehr nicht. Und fünf Liter ist eine Menge. Fünf Liter ist wirklich so ein Junk, einfach so wirklich so ein ordentliches Ding. Ja, aber ganz ehrlich, jetzt irgendwann kommt doch auch, also allein Wasser wäre ja teurer. Ja, ich habe geguckt, es ist im Supermarkt das billigste Getränk, Wasser mit eingeschlossen. Fünf Liter ein Euro, es gibt drei köstliche Geschmacksrichtungen, Kirsch, Multivitamin und Orange. Es gehört schon so amerikanische Verhältnisse, wo Familien, die nicht so viel Geld haben, wahrscheinlich eher das kaufen als Wasser, weil es billiger ist. Und ich verstehe dieses Zeug nicht. Was ist denn da drin? Nichts, fast nichts. Es ist Wasser. Achtung, zweiter Fakt, Kalorien pro hundert Milliliter, eine. Also mehr als Wasser. Eine einzige. Also wir sind nährstofftechnisch leicht über Wasser und ich baller mir das Zeug rein, als gäbe es kein Morgen. Wirklich, ich habe die, also das ballert natürlich alles weg, so eine reine Chemie. Niemand, ich weiß nicht genau, was da drin ist, ich dachte mir bei einem Kalorie, okay, da ist Süssmiss.
Das ist Mr. Max.
Es ist das weirdeste Produkt der Welt.
Es ist so ein Randprodukt, für das nicht geworben wird.
Das findest du in Getränkemärkten irgendwo ganz in der Ecke, ganz oben.
Ich habe es noch nie gesehen, glaube ich.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, wenn du eine Familie mit ganz vielen Kindern hast und
du willst dir nicht Cola kaufen oder so,
kaufst du diese fünf Kilo
Dinger.
Ja, ich habe gerade ein Bild gefunden, das ist eine sehr
ungesündeste Farbe,
weil es dieses
ich versuche so zu tun, als wäre ich
orangenbasiert, aber die Farbe
sagt, noch nie im Leben hat irgendein Tropfen dieser Flüssigkeit jemals eine Orange gesehen.
Nee, nee.
Auch, also das Etikett ist das hässlichste, was ich jemals gesehen habe, also wie du schon sagst, entgegen aller Trends mit Chicken Production Design und so weiter. Und natürlich der geschmackvolle Papiertragegriff auch noch oben. Dieses Ding ist so schwer, dass da noch so ein Klebebandgriff dran ist, der natürlich schön einfach direkt in die Finger schneidet. Solltest du auf die dumme Idee kommen, das tatsächlich zu greifen. Ich habe im Internet nichts darüber gefunden, was das ist, ob da Süßstoff drin ist, was das ist, und ich glaube, das ist ... Ich bin jetzt auf der Seite openfoodfacts.org.
So, Nutri-Score, nicht berechnet.
Unbekannte Lebensmittelqualität.
Nova.
Das beschreibt es genau.
Das müssen die aufs Etikett schreiben.
Unbekannte Lebensmittelqualität.
Nova ist ein Score, nicht berechnet.
Grad der Lebensmittelverarbeitung unbekannt.
Eco-Score, keine Ahnung.
Unbekannte Umweltauswirkungen.
Produkteigenschaft.
Das ist kein gutes Zeichen.
Unbekannte Natur.
Es klingt wie eine Simpsons-Episode, wo wir gerade drin sind.
Home-Health und Drink rausgebracht.
Allgemeiner Name, Erfrischungsgetränk mit mehr Fruchtgeschmack.
Klingt auch so, als ob sie Multivitamin umgehen wollen mit mehr Fruchtgeschmarrt. Ja, genau, undefinierte Früchte. Mengenangabe, fünf Liter. A der Verpackung, obviously Kunststoff. Marken, Mr. Max, Kategorien, Getränke, Kohlensäure, halte ich Kohlensäure drin? Nee, ist keine Kohlensäure drin. Erflussgetränke, Zucker, Getränke. Also ich hätte bis jetzt nur Kirsch. So, Zutaten sind sehr viel dafür, dass es so wenig kostet,
ist sehr viel drin, ehrlich gesagt.
Allerdings.
Wasser, Säure, Regulator, Zitronensäure,
Stabilisatoren.
Wie so ein Reaktor.
Wie sie plötzlich umfällt auf dem Küchentisch.
Das klingt wie das, was ich in Chernobyl gelernt habe,
was am Ende erklärt wird im Gerichtssaal,
was gegeneinander wirkt. Stabilisatoren und Zucker. Farbstoffe, sehr viel Farbstoffe und dann sehr viele Süßungsmittel. Wenige Vitamine auch. Ja, Vitamine sind drin. Und ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob du so amerikanische Footballfilme kennst. Und auch bei Ted Lasso, wer das gerade schaut, da gibt es immer diesen Fruitmix Vielleicht ist es mir aufgefallen, bei so einem Football Film, die haben immer diese grossen Kanister und oft, wenn das Team gewinnt, schütten die die über die Coaches drüber. Und ich dachte immer, das wäre so eine Art Mountain Dew oder sowas. Aber das sind ja Sportler. Power Rate. Die können nicht so viele Zucker trinken. Ich glaube, sowas ist das. So eine Art Frucht-Wasser-Mischung weird... Das ist so ganz merkwürdig, weil das passt auch in keine Konsum-Tradition rein. Man trinkt es nicht mal ein Glas zum Mittagessen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das konsumieren soll. Das sind fünf Liter. Und ich habe die alle weggeballert an einem Tag. Und du hast die komplett weggetrunken. Das war der schönste Tag meines Lebens. Ja, war es ein schöner Tag. Hast du dich aber gut gefühlt? Nein, nein, überhaupt nicht. Ich würde das gar nicht trinken. Du kriegst diesen Geschmack nicht mehr los, du kriegst den Geschmack nicht los. Das ist das Ding. Sie boosten einen Drink. Nein, nein, so schlimm ist es nicht. Aber vor allem das Tolle ist, du sagst, du würdest es gar nicht trinken. Ich fühle mich auf eine ganz merkwürdige Art hingezogen zu dieser Art wahnsinnig billigen Produkten, so richtig schlechten Nahrung. Ich fühle mich da hingezogen. Ich fühle mich da nur hingezogen, wenn ich in Amerika bin. Wenn wir in New York sind die Woche immer, dann mache ich das auch gerne, dann all in gehen und so. Aber hier in Deutschland will ich mich nicht schlecht fühlen, nachdem ich was kommt. Aber ein Kalorie ein Kalorie, das hat nichts. Fünf Liter sind 50 Kalorien. Weißt du, Zigaretten haben auch keine Kalorien. Und trotzdem ballerst du die nicht rein. Styropor hat auch keine Kalorien. Perfekt für jede Diät geeignet. Ja, Metall. In den Tisch beißen oder so hier. Aber da bin ich gerade kulinarisch angekommen. Wo du bei Lavendelpasta bist, bin ich bei einfach dieser synthetisch hergestellten Flüssigkeit, die chemisch gar nicht zuordnen war. Also, wollt ihr meinen viel zu teuren, lächerlich gut verpackten, mit so mega sleeker, sleekem Produktdesign meinen Stefan-Tietze Lavendel-Tee haben? Oder wollt ihr Florentins acht Liter? Florenti, zehn Liter ein Euro. Zehn Liter ein Euro, unbekannter Eco-Score-Kram haben. Ich will den Kanister, ich will den Griff haben. Gutes Produkt erkennt man immer am Griff. Und zwar auch so ein Orang-Utan-FFell gemachten Griff. Ja. Ich sag dir, ich gehe in so ein Lebensmittellabor hin und sage, ihr kriegt ein Fakt von mir, zehn Liter ein Euro. Go, shoot. Der Rest ist mir egal. Die billigsten Sachen. Alle Rapper starten Eistees. Was ich an dieser ganzen Diskussion so spannend finde, ist, dass die ja, wie startet man den Prozess, wie starte ich jetzt den Weg dahin zu meinem Eistee?
Wir waren kurz davor, einen eigenen Schokoriegel zu haben.
Wir waren ja mal davor ein eigener Schokoriegel. Für gute Arbeit war ja die Idee rückblickend unsagbar dämlich und vielleicht auch Grund. Von Anfang an war das Projekt zum Standardverurteilt, weil wir hatten ein bisschen Geld für Werbung. Und wir haben uns überlegt, wir bringen einen Trailer raus für einen Indie-Film, der heißt Gute Arbeit, hat aber sonst nichts mit irgendwas zu tun und hat keinen Inhalt. Leute waren verwirrt. Das war alles, was es gemacht hat. Ja, Werbe, Wirkung, Verwirrung. Werbe, Wirkung, Verwirrung hat schlecht getestet, auch in der Marktforschung. Dann zwei, weiß ich nicht mehr. Die Morningshow, die gute Arbeit Morningshow, wo wir extra Simon Kretschmer und die Tienga D durch ganz Deutschland gefahren haben, was nicht billig ist, damit sie kurz aufflackern im Trailer für die Morningshow, war auch nicht billig. Und der dritte Teil sollte eigentlich unser eigener Schokoriege werden. Aber dann haben sie uns, was ich rückblickend verstehe, das Geld weggenommen. Für dieitte Säule unseres auszuklügenden Werbeprogramms. Wir haben schon überwiesen 150.000 Euro an Haribo und Funk hat sich da zwischeneingehängt und hat diese Übertragung einfach abgefangen und das Geld wieder zurückgehoben. Funk hat sich rückblickend nicht klar schützend vor wen geschmissen, aber Funk ist... Vor der Gesundheit der deutschen Bürger, glaube ich. Wäre unser Schunkurier auf den Markt gekommen, ja, gute Nacht, Johanna, das wäre es gewesen. Gute Nacht, Johanna. Das wäre es wirklich gewesen. Ich frage mich jetzt rückblickend wirklich, wäre der gut gewesen. Unsere Idee war nämlich irgendwann mal angelangt, dass wir Fruchtgummi mit Schokolade kombinieren wollten. Eine Kombination, die sie noch nicht durchgesetzt hat, aber trotzdem köstlich ist. Frage, hat sie sich nicht durchgesetzt, weil die Scheiße ist, die Kombination, oder hat sie sich durchgesetzt, weil einfach niemand auf die Idee gekommen ist. Weil ich finde es ja immer noch ganz gut, also weil Jaffa-Cakes sind ja ähnlich, da gibt es ein bisschen Schokolade und es gibt halt diesen Fruchtgummi-artigen, aber es ist ja nicht wirklich Goldbeeren-Fruchtgummi. Ja, die Idee war ein Schokoriegel mit einem Fruchtgummi-Kern. Und wir standen mit einem grossen deutschen Fruchtgummihersteller im Kontakt. Sag euch den Namen. Haribo. Wirklich Haribo? Ja, wir haben ein Mail geschrieben und sie sagten, wir wollen uns eine eigene Schokoriegel machen, habt ihr Bock? Und die so, ja. Aber die haben, glaube ich, gesagt, ab 100.000 macht das Sinn. Genau, wir wollten so 100 Riegel und die so, nee, nee, wir fangen bei 100 Tonnen an. Ich glaube, es ist vieler Satz in der Mail, dafür schmeissen wir die Maschinen nicht an oder so was. Also es ist viel so ein sehr pragmatischer Satz, wo ich dachte, ach okay, aber ich schmeisse eure Maschinen an. Ja, aber das ist auch eine Sprache, die man versteht. Einfach sagt, ach so, die müssen die anschmeissen erst mal. Ja, ja, die müssen die erstmal anschmeissen. Die müssen zum grossen Seil so. Da kommt dann morgens jemand da rein und macht die erst mal an.
Aber was ist das für eine Fabrik, die einfach on the fly verschiedenste Sachen herstellen kann, oder?
Stellt dieselbe Maschine Snickers und Bounty her oder sind es zwei verschiedene Maschinen?
Gute Frage. Ich möchte gerne einen Riegel rausbringen, der heißt das Podcast UFO.
Ja.
Und ich möchte ihn gerne rausbringen. Und zwar soll der beinhalten Lavendel Mr. Max. Lavendel Mr. Max. So heißt der. Also Mr. Max in Lavendel-Geschmack oder was? Oder Lavendel mit Mr. Max-Geschmack. Eins von beiden. Aber ich hätte gerne Schokolade, aber bei mir ist immer ich habe immer das Gefühl, es wird eine Schokolade gespart, ausserhalb des Riegels, weißt du, ich habe immer das Gefühl, es wird nur so einmal mal unter so einem Schokoladenstrahl so durchgeworfen, so eine ganz dünne Schokoladenschicht. Ja. Ich will so eine richtig, so eine ein Zentimeter dicke Schokoladenschicht haben. So ein kalter Hund mässig, wo du dich so richtig durchbeissen musst. Da muss man sich nicht durchbeissen. Ja. Und zwar, und da drin ist ein Fruchtgummikern. Oder so Goldbeeren, aber mit Lavendelgeschmack. Du hast einfach eine Schokohülle und darin ist ein Bounty. Also du nimmst einfach ein Bounty, packst es aus, machst noch eine Schicht Schokolade drüber, verkaufst das als das Podcast-Ufo. Für alle, die sagen, ich liebe Bounty, aber es ist mir zu wenig Schokolade. Ist auch hier, ich habe mit einem Kumpel am Wochenende diese Listen gemacht und habe Süßigkeiten bewertet. Und wir haben die Celebration-Süßigkeiten bewertet, von sehr gut bis sehr schlecht. Und bei ihm war Bounty auf Platz eins. Und ich habe das beim besten Willen nicht angesehen, wie man Bounty auf Platz einsetzen kann. Ich habe auch gerade von Bounty gesprochen. Leute lieben Bounty. Ja, ich mag Bounty. Es ist ein guter Erfrischungssnack. Es muss halt natürlich eiskalt sein, wenn du da so ein labbriges, warmes Ding haben willst. Aber ich glaube, es ist so schön einfach. So schön einfach, weil es wirklich nur zwei Zutaten sind, kannst du dich da so richtig reinlegen. Kokoskram und Schoko. Ja. Das ist alles im Baunten.
Ist aber auch wirklich Kram, ne? Es ist nicht einfach nur
Kokos, es ist schon Kokoskram. Es ist schon Kokoskram.
Da muss man schon wirklich, glaube ich, in die Details gehen, um zu
verstehen, was das ist. Weiß ich gar nicht.
Ich habe letztens wollte ich eine Kokosnuss
konsumieren, habe mir eine Kokosnuss gekauft,
wusste nicht, was jemand anfangen soll.
Wie aufgebrochen, das Zeug ist mir ins Gesicht gespritzt,
es war schon abgestanden, ich glaube, es war gegoren,
ich glaube, die war faul, dann wollte ich die essen und die war weich und die hat überhaupt nicht geschmeckt und dann hatte ich Husten. Das war ein unangenehmes Erlebnis allgemein. Dann hast du Husten. Das ist einer der Gründe, warum ich Bounty einer normalen Kokosnuss vorziehe, weil es gibt wenig Ersatz für Bounty. Erdnüsse kannst du auch so essen, da hast du schon mal die Meister in Schokolade. Raffaello. Weil Raffaello hält sich schön zurück an deinen Kokosnussfront. Und bringt noch diesen Haselnuss, diese kennt man hier, Haselnuss rein. Aber schön auch ein bisschen Kokos, Haselnusscreme. Ich glaube, der Schokoriegelmarkt ist wirklich durch. Ich glaube, wir müssen auf dem Eistee-Markt oder vielleicht halt den nächsten Eistee machen. Wenn jetzt alle Rapper die Eistees rausgebracht haben und der Markt übersättigt ist, was kommt als nächstes? Vielleicht so Raumdüfte, so Raumerfrischer wie diese Bäume. Ich habe das Gefühl, die haben ein ziemliches Monopol. Immer wenn du diese, weil selbst Ocean's Eleven oder so benutzen diesen Baum. Der Wunderbaum. Der Wunderbaum. Ich glaube, das ist ein Markt, das ist ein Monopol, das kann man denen aus der Hand reißen. Weil wenn du sagst, Lavendel bietet sich super an als Geruch und du machst so ein Gesicht von Stefan T. Und die Leute haben dein Gesicht, die ganze Zeit im Gesicht, wenn sie ihr Auto fahren und einen herrlichen Lavendelgeruch. Oder wir machen es so leicht anders, so Wunderstrauch. Das ist eine Strauchform. Ja, genau. Ja, oder es ist so ein Laubbaum. Wunderbusch. Nicht so ein Tannenbaum, sondern ein Laubbaum. Ja, genau. Das finde ich auch nicht schlecht. So was könnte man gut machen. Ja, das finde ich auch nicht so schlecht.
Und dann bringen aber auch, dann bringen wieder alle
Jazzmusiker Deutschlands, bringen ihren eigenen
Wunderbaum raus und dann geht's da wieder los.
Das sind eh die nervigsten, die ganzen
Jazzmusiker, die hier rumlaufen. Ja, wirklich
in jeder Sendung ständig immer
Es reicht
jetzt, Ruhe. Warst du mal in einem Jazzclub?
Ja, klar. Ich war in New York im Jazzclub.
Nee, warst du mal in Köln im Jazzclub. In München war ich im Jazzclub, Voglerbar, damals ... Weiß ich noch. Gibt's hier in Köln einen Jazzclub, ja. Warst du schon mal da? Nein. Warum nicht? Keine Lust. Livemusik, was ist gegen Livemusik? Warum hast du Livemusik? Warum hast du Freude? Ich war auf ein paar Konzerten und es ist mir zu voll und ich mag oft nur ein Lied von dem Künstler. Dann warte ich, bis das Lied kommt, dann kommt das Lied, dann nehme ich mir, ja, dafür habe ich jetzt gewartet. Dafür habe ich gewartet und dann sind so Vollidioten stehen neben mir und unterhalten sich und ich denke mir, ihr geht auf ein Live-Konzert, um euch zu unterhalten. Jetzt auch mal die Lust, ja, dann werden die mal noch lauter, wenn die Musik lauter wird und man denkt, ja, jetzt habt ihr es nicht verstanden. Ein Grad an Lächerlichkeit angenommen, ihr merkt selbst. Man hat nämlich das Gefühl, Leute gehen auf Veranstaltungen und sind dann von der Veranstaltung gestört. Also die wollen sich unterhalten und dann wird die Musik lauter und dann drücken die näher und halten sich so die Ohren zu und sagen, ja auf jeden Fall habe ich dann zu ihr gesagt. Und ich so, Leute, ihr müsst hier nicht sein. Ihr müsst nicht sein, ihr könnt woanders sein. Es gibt andere Orte. Easy. Ihr könnt easy woanders sein. Und dann stellt sich heraus, es war der Tontechniker. Ja, meine Güte, der mit dem Brandschutzbeauftragten beredet hat. Weil eine akute Brandgefahr bestand. Und die Feuermelder nicht funktioniert haben. Und die Pyros schiefgegangen. Und der Eck durfte davon nichts wissen. Aber sie konnten nicht ihrer Arbeit nachgehen, weil ich zur ganze Zeit gerufen habe, ihr müsst hier nicht sein. Und dann bin ich nach Hause gegangen und der Laden ist abgefackelt. So war das, die Geschichte vom abgebrannten Konzerthaus. Konzerthaus. Ich bin der Meinung, wir haben unsere Pflicht für die Woche durch deine zehn Gags gemacht. Ja, wir haben schon auf die Liste, wir haben genug abgehakt. Wir wünschen euch eine fantastische Woche, haut rein, seid auch nächste Woche wieder mit dabei. Wenn es wieder heißt. Wenn es wieder heißt, herzlich willkommen zu das Podcast-Ufo, schickt uns eure Intros ein, vielen, vielen Dank, nehmt euch ein Vorbild an Randy, kurz und knackig, cool. Schickt schnelle, süße Intros, nehmt mit dem Orchester auf meinetwegen, aber schön kurz.
Schön kurz, wir freuen uns über jedes Haut rein, macht's gut, habt einen schönen Abend noch.
Eine sehr schöne Woche, ciao!
Wir machen's gut, ciao!